hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful and more enjoyable so
in this video we're going to do is we're
going to continue on with our matrix
series of videos and we're going to talk
about how to find the inverse of a
matrix okay so when you look at a matrix
okay I've just denoted this as ABC and D
okay and we're going to be working with
two-by-two matrices in this video but to
find the determinant what you want to do
is you want to interchange the a and the
D okay so you're going to put D here and
a there you're going to keep the B and
the C in the same position but you're
going to make them the opposite sign so
I've written negative B and negative C
so that just represents the opposite of
being the opposite of C and E we
switched and then what you're gonna do
is you're going to divide all of these
elements by the determinant the
determinant of the original matrix okay
which is ad minus BC okay so let's take
a look at an example so in this example
here first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
just going to take the determinant so
that's going to be 6 minus 4 so this
diagonal multiplied together
- this diagonal multiplied together so 6
minus 4 is 2 so I'm just going to write
the determinant equals 2 now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to switch these
elements on the diagonal so I'm going to
put 2 here 3 here I'm going to make the
B and the C the opposite so that's
negative 4 and negative 1 we want to
divide all the elements here by the
determinate which is 2 ok and you can
see that this is going to be our inverse
matrix I'll simplify it a little bit
further here for us so it's 1 negative 2
negative 1/2 and 3 halves
okay and so this is our inverse matrix
now one of the neat things about inverse
matrices is that if you multiply a
matrix by its inverse that's what the a
minus 1 represents you're going to get
this interesting matrix here which has a
1 on the diagonal and zeros everywhere
else that's called I the identity matrix
and the interesting thing about the
identity matrix is like the number one
if you take the identity matrix times
any other matrix of the same size okay
you're going to get the same identical
thing back just like when you multiply
by number
1 times 7 is 7 1 times 10 is 10 the
identity matrix times another matrix
will give you that original matrix back
ok just like multiplying by 1 so let's
just see if we can again experiment with
that a little bit so let's take this
matrix and its inverse so that's going
to be 3 1 4 2 okay and we're going to
multiply by its inverse which is 1
negative 2 negative 1/2 and 3 halves
okay so we know from previous video that
we take the rows times the columns right
so let's go ahead and do that so first
row first column that gives us 3 minus 2
which is 1 first row second column that
gives us 2 negative 6 times positive 6
or which is 0 ok so you just multiply
rules times columns and then the second
row first column we get 1 and negative 2
halves which is negative ones 1 plus
negative 1 is 0 and then the second row
second column we get negative 2 and
let's see what is this positive 3 which
is 1 so you can see we get the identity
matrix which is itself and just to show
you what the identity matrix let's just
say we had 1 0 0 1 or identity matrix ok
now let's just say we multiply it by the
matrix 1 2 3 4 ok just real basic so
first row first column that gives us 1
and 0 which is 1 first row second column
that gives us 2 plus 0 which is 2 second
row first column that gives us 0 plus 3
which is 3 second row second column 2
times 0 is 0 1 times 4 is 4 we add those
together we get 4 and you can see we're
getting the same identical matrix back
just like we're multiplying by by the
number 1 ok also get one more example I
hope you're enjoying these videos if you
are subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you in the future videos and
continue on with this series to learn
more about matrices you can see there's
a link up up above to see those but last
example here so we're going to find the
determinant ok of this matrix and then
we're going to go on to find the inverse
so what we want to do is want to take
this diagonal 10 minus this diagonal
negative 8 so 10 minus negative 8 gives
us a determinant of 18 we're going to
switch the
elements on this diagonal so I'm going
to write this as two and five we're
going to make the ones I miss diagonal
the opposite sign so four and negative
two and we're going to divide everything
by the determinant of the original
matrix not the new matrix okay and there
is our inverse matrix now if you want
you can reduce these fractions further
to make a little bit nicer and neater so
subscribe to the channel keep on with
the videos of learning more about
matrices and I'll see you in the next
video